so this is good the villainous cult
leader in Olivia Wilde's new movie don't
worry darling has been based off of my
dad because apparently he's King of the
incels we're gonna go through some
articles Rolling Stone
Olivia Wilde Chris Pines don't worry
darling character inspired by incel Hero
Jordan Peterson in the film Pine plays
Frank the founder of the mysterious
Victory project which is behind the
seemingly idyllic 1950s town where the
main characters Jack played by Harry
Styles and Alice live wild explained
that Frank was partly based on this
insane man Jordan Peterson who is this
pseudo-intellectual hero to the incel
community
uh well Olivia Wilde is where I go to
get my intellectual recommendations let
me see what's her background
she went to acting school okay now
no hate for acting school I actually
don't have a University degree I did two
years of Classics in Psychology and two
years of biomedical science and then I
dropped out to start making money so no
hate there but she probably should have
actually watched my dad before basing
one of her characters off of it rather
than getting all her information from
sound bites probably from BuzzFeed wild
elaborated this guy Jordan Peterson is
someone that legitimizes certain aspects
of their movement because he's a former
Professor he's an author he wears a suit
she knows some things about my dad so
they feel like this is a real philosophy
that should be taken seriously and then
Rolling Stone says let's just hope this
doesn't give the guy an inadvertent ego
boost which unfortunately it probably
will well I don't know about my dad but
it's given me an ego boost at least for
the day Chris Pine as my dad
beautiful so if you search this movie
apparently Shia LaBeouf was fired from
it apparently the female actress
Florence Pugh has not been promoting it
because she's uncomfortable for some
reason and apparently Olivia is not very
nice to work with here's a photo of her
in a mask the future is female
ejaculation
uh okay anyway you guys can think
whatever you think about that apparently
there are a bunch of oh my gosh her
Instagram oh my gosh okay well
nobody is taking this chick seriously
I'm going back to the mainstream news
articles that also people probably
aren't taking seriously the independent
the independent don't worry darling
Olivia Wilde says Chris Pine's
terrifying character is based on insane
Jordan Peterson
she further explained that incels as a
community of disenfranchised mostly
white men who believe they are entitled
to sex from women my dad is not
pro-in-cell I believe there was a clip
from Joe Rogan I'm actually going to
pull it up so you're a young man and all
the women are rejecting you
who's got the problem
it's not all the women
that's a bad road to go down if all the
women are rejecting you oh my gosh it's
you
it's Dad
hello hello rap girl hey can I Facetime
you for a second yep hey okay so I've
got hilarious news I don't know if
you've heard about it already
this is exciting dad you want to hear it
it's almost as good as Red Skull
so apparently you have been written in
as the villain to Olivia Wilde's new
movie because it gets better because
you're you're King of the incels oh
really
so Rolling Stone wrote about it Olivia
Wilde Chris Pines don't worry darling
character inspired by incel Hero Jordan
Peterson
wow how many how many scientific papers
have you written
published how many have you published
[Music]
[Music]
so pseudo-intellectual isn't how you
would be described
okay so I'm convinced that Olivia Wilde
is secretly a Jordan Peterson fan
otherwise I don't know why you would
cast such a terrifying character as
Chris Pine uh so thank you for that
that's really funny uh anyway this is
just another
weird thing that happens in the life of
the Petersons I suppose but I'm
definitely going to be watching this
video I probably wouldn't have heard of
it so
thank you